[Music]
welcome to episode 191 of
congratulations
[Music]
oh yeah here we are um if you're if
you're watching this
not if you're watching this because that
is how i started this podcast already
first word is wrong i said yf instead of
f
uh if you're watching this podcast
you're noticing something different and
it's not that i got a haircut which
um i actually do need to do i need to
[ __ ] trim it up a little bit
uh it's been a while and you know how i
do it with my haircut i cut it and i
keep cutting it and i cut it a little
bit it takes about four days
and i notice a certain [ __ ] is long and
so i gotta cut the side and whatever i
gotta cut the other side
a day later because it's not long enough
whatever the [ __ ] you know how it is
but um yeah we got a new [ __ ]
background um
and uh it's not necessarily here to stay
uh we're going through some changes and
uh that's it man
uh so uh it'll be different next week
and it might be different even the week
after that but we're figuring [ __ ] out
we wanted we want to um update
everything and that's what's going on so
yeah so that's it
nothing funny about that but you know
it's just
got to get a little bit we got to get a
little bit of news out of the way first
we gotta get a little bit of news out of
the way first
and uh and we just did and that's great
and so now we're on to a silly goose
time
and we're on to a silly goose time um
live in the congratulations studio um i
don't know i'm feeling good dude you
know
i try to wake up and i check in with
myself i breath i do breathing
i mean we all do breathing but sometimes
i think about my breathing
and uh feels good um i
uh i'm i'm i'm i'm a i'm a good i'm good
my one time my brother was [ __ ]
had this uh asian friend that barely
spoke english in elementary school
and um they were talking about baseball
and he said
and he said i'm a good instead of i'm
good and we think about it all the time
because that's [ __ ] hilarious a
[ __ ]
asian kid in elementary school wanted to
say how good at baseball he was and he
said i'm a good
i'm a good that's hilarious and his name
was will
something but anyway uh i loved when i
was a [ __ ] in high school there were
so many asian kids in my high school
and dude they were they all had names
like [ __ ] chuck and henry
uh it was like dude it was like the old
[ __ ]
it was like the old school names that
they the the asians came over
to [ __ ] the to america and they were
like
they use these names right
it's like what should we name them
gregory pick
[Laughter]
what should we name them gregory
humphrey
um they just saw old move so the guy's
name was like [ __ ]
humphrey suck or [ __ ]
henry lim or harvey
harvey harvey and whatever you [ __ ]
get it harvey lim that one always
threw me for a loop there was kim lee
and then all of a sudden there'd be like
a a
korean dude with the last name lim and
you're like oh all right
okay mixing it up a little bit um
and uh one time i almost got a fight
actually in
in in in the in high school and these
asian kids were in my
in my face now and he was like what's up
honky and i was like dude don't be
racist and he said
i'm not racist at all kp which is korean
power and i was like
worst lawyer um
case case dismissed immediately um
so yeah dude uh chilling having a good
time
i got a [ __ ] i got uh
this is from oh i [ __ ] have you guys
ever seen this
i didn't mean to talk about this but now
since i am
this is the greatest thing of all time
maybe but this is from the 1990s
baseball video game where a japanese
game decide
designer had to make up a bunch of quote
unquote american names
this is a [ __ ] meme i guess
but it's real though this is these are
actual names
that were in an americanized
japanese baseball game
and this is great steve
mcdickal okay so
[ __ ] off color and don't even know it
onsen sweemi
daryl archideld
daryl archidel daryl archidel stands
up to the plate swinging a miss antoli
smarin
coming in from the bullpen gives
daryl archidel a uh
a run for his money swinging miss strike
one
uh and totally winds up for the pitch
and hit
long fly ball deep to center and ray
mcshriff is there to
make the catch did glenn allen nixon
mario
maker lane wow this one has [ __ ] four
consonants in a row there's no word in
the english language i think that
maybe there is but mick mcroll of wayne
raul chamberlain
oh dude that sounds like a [ __ ] tom
cruise character
that's like that when his name was
anderton [ __ ] anderton dude a
japanese guy wrote uh
[ __ ] whatever that movie was what the
[ __ ] is that called
not i what the [ __ ] is a movie called
the blue one this whole movie's blue
minority report dude his name's anderton
minority report and that the whole
movie's blue
and he's and and it's like dude just
name a [ __ ] anderson dude it's a
movie who gives a [ __ ] you don't need to
get creative with the last name
let's put a t instead of the s dude
raymix riff
uh kevin no gilney
tony shmerrick
oh this one's the best one bobson dugnut
oh dude sounds so sexual
hi how you doing i'm bob i'm i'm bobson
dugnut
let's leave honey willy dustis
jerome gride scott dork
dorkay shone fur coat
dean wesseri mike truck
that one would be a real one dwight
oh wow dwight rorchagel
you know just took the p off portugal
and added an r
lazy tim sandale
carl oh this one is a might be my
favorite carl
dandelton mike
hernandez wow dude
how did they get it so far off how did
they
rather how did they miss it with just
one letter like you almost had it
it's fernandez and just
the guy's like i'm pretty sure it's an s
it's like
i think it i think it's an f no we're
gonna go with
sernandes and then this one
todd gonzalez which should be gonzalez
but then no [ __ ] mexican is named
todd
todd's the whitest [ __ ] name i ever
heard
todd i knew a guy named todd that only
wore shorts no matter how cold it was
and one time i asked him to close his
eyes and i i i said close your eyes and
tell me what you're wearing and he
couldn't do it
these are the games we play on set dude
these are the games we play on set i
said hey todd close your eyes
and he goes like this and i said what do
you wear and he said i don't remember
dude that's a fun game no matter what
and my girl always wants to [ __ ] play
scattergories or some [ __ ] when i'm like
why can't we just close our eyes and see
how
dumb we are [ __ ] dude those are
the games i [ __ ] do
one time i grabbed one of the i grabbed
a showrunner's phone to understand i
don't do pranks but when i do
they are the legit pranks that was
legitness
when i do pranks that were legitness
that was that was legitness when i do
pranks they're the legit shits
i don't do when anyone if you're gonna
hurt somebody or like be
funny george clooney where you light
somebody's shoe on fire and they all
gotta [ __ ] pat it out and they're
scared for their lives
no want to know the pranks i do dude
one time i got a show runner's phone and
i took the and i texted
the ad hey we need a frog outfit
and we need to um we need to hire
a a red-headed actor and we got to put a
frog
a frog outfit in it in him put him in a
frog outfit
and [ __ ] deleted the text
that i sent from the showrunner boom no
trace
i waited and the ad wrote on it boom
deleted it no trace gave the phone back
to the showrunner
and the race for finding the frog outfit
was on dude and i told him we needed to
buy tomorrow
and he was stressing the [ __ ] out the
whole day dude
and i was giggling man i was giggling
hard and that's it
and i [ __ ] he caught me giggling and
i was like bro you don't need to get
that outfit
i was just joking and he was like [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you i still keep in touch with
that [ __ ] because he gets it
dude
find people that get it keep them in
your life weed out the
others keep them in your life keep that
circle tight as [ __ ]
make the others bounce around on the
side but i want to get in but i want to
get in
oh really you shouldn't have [ __ ]
betrayed me ping
you bounced the [ __ ] off like a coat on
to strip his ass
dude ron zales
what was it rortugal
didn't try
i love it dude my
goal when i was in hollywood trying to
do this [ __ ]
my goal was to be a [ __ ]
liam neeson type dude i was gonna take
my career
as comedy and parlay it into [ __ ]
action movie star
that's what i wanted to do but i
i i still [ __ ] love liam neeson
and there's a new movie coming out from
leon uh by
with liam neeson in it i said like he
directed and produced it
and it's called the ice road trailer and
it is
[ __ ] this trailer is hilarious
because
it's called the ice road trailer of the
ice road not the eyesore trailer
which would be something completely
different but this [ __ ] dude
keeps being in movies and even if
they're not
[ __ ] um even if they're not
what do you call it action movies they
have to be action movies
this movie that he made is not an action
movie
but it turns into an action movie before
the trailer is done and
you're like okay okay i get it liam
neeson is in it and he has to kill
everybody in this movie it's like before
like schindler's list was the last one
where he was like that's the last one
i'm going to do
and now i'm going to kill everybody you
put movie script
and i kill everybody if you want me to
be in driving miss daisy the reboot
i'm going to have to kill everybody
including miss daisy
like that's the that's liam neeson mode
right there
so there's this movie coming out the ice
road and it's just a drama
here we go
what the hell was that just a drama
just a drama they had an avalanche
miners are trying to get out gets uh
yeah i'm putting together a rescue
mission
we have 26 trapped miners who are
running out of air there you go
that's what the movie's about we have 26
trap miners
that are running out of air that's what
the movie's about [ __ ] liam neeson
gets a call from uh morpheus
and then morpheus is like hey dude these
miners are trapped let's go do this and
liam neeson is like okay let's do this
and then they just got to like dig and
it's like a [ __ ] movie where he's
like trying to get
underground and get these guys before
they run out of air and he has to find
these guys
but what does he really have to find he
has to find out who he is that's what he
has to do right because you know he's
got a wife that's [ __ ]
left him ah you were too [ __ ] you're
too much with your job i'm not gonna be
with you you want to see your kid then
[ __ ] you stop stop trying to save
[ __ ] miners you know
stop trying to save all these miners
everyone [ __ ]
these miners are trapped and we have to
[ __ ] save them every now and then
and they're just like yeah but we just
you're losing your family you're finding
these my
you're finding these people in these
mines but you're losing your family
that's what the movie's about that's
what the [ __ ] movie's about right
here
we're [ __ ] a minute no what is it
20 20 [ __ ] six seconds in you know
what the movie's about
cool great liam neeson getting back to
schindler's list mode
so let's continue dude 300 feet of pipe
delivered up there
in under 30 hours they need to deliver
the [ __ ] pipe
to the miners that's what they need to
do dude
can you make it happen morpheus doesn't
know if he can make it happen dude
experience on the ice rodent yep look at
he's a mechanic
i love it dude you have experience with
this ice road
yes i do do you want to do it i
guarantee it's this scene no
i don't want to do it those days are
long gone but we need you i can't
and then a scene later
hello one condition
and he's in dude that's how the movie
goes he has like an argument with his
wife he realized
his kid doesn't think he's a man all
right hello
i'll do it yes
jesus give me 50 bucks one of my drivers
just became available what's it for
i love it i i love it i love it dude i
love it i love it one of my drivers just
became available who is it a [ __ ]
four foot six woman i love it
dude hollywood keeps it woke
hey what's up i'll drive
bail uh yeah what told you this wasn't
gonna be easy
it's not gonna be easy because you can't
reach the pedals i'm in
she's a badass she can get careful here
we go line up
the only way up there is crossing the
ice roads boring movie
has been falling for five weeks now look
what dude wow
he's getting more irish the older he he
gets honestly
he's more irish now liam neeson is just
crossing the ice roads
right here has been falling for five
weeks now it's only been throwing for
five weeks now
that is not how he sounded in [ __ ]
take him taken
he was like i will find her and i will
get her and now it's they've been
thawing for five weeks now
dude they've been flying for five weeks
now
we've gotta run cause our legs are short
because we're leprechauns
just that one scene him running
one scene running really quickly you see
and you notice he's got a green hat
grab me hat
every movie he does he gets a little bit
more irish you look he's got a [ __ ]
orange
[ __ ] [ __ ] chin what do they call it
[ __ ] goatee
one of those little french beards just
in one shot he turns around boom
his hat he turns up so so quickly his
hat [ __ ] runs over and a four-leaf
clover falls out and he's got the [ __ ]
chin
we've gotta find it's been falling it's
about to thaw me lady
[Laughter]
running dude running with a bowl
pink and [ __ ] green things are
falling out like what is it that's
me lucky charms we need to get them to
the miners they haven't had food for
weeks
grab me hot grab me lucky charms
oh [ __ ] i can't wait to shave this
position when i'm done saving this
miners
you know did you just roll your r now
that was all in your
imagination laddie
holy damn the day today as he's getting
the [ __ ]
dude hide it on it in the minor the
miners are like do you hear that
what is that
is that i think it's a guy coming to
save us what the [ __ ] is he a leprechaun
he has to because he's the only one
small enough that could [ __ ] fit
through these cracks
and then he comes into it i'll give you
a mouth to mouth a little [ __ ]
leprechaun on the guy's face
farting into his mouth using his ass
[ __ ] to [ __ ] give him cpr
so gross dude [ __ ] sitting on
sitting on the [ __ ] guys in the
cave's faces to [ __ ]
i gotta clear
i [ __ ] a little bit laddie he's dead and
he's dead and he's got
[ __ ] on his mouth laddie
if they are able to accomplish this we
will be exposed
but see this is still just a boring
movie
we've been sabotaged oh there it is dude
you thought it was gonna be a [ __ ]
movie where a guy finds himself
you thought it was gonna be a movie or a
guy just needs to go over this long
stretch of land
with a bunch of other dudes and a lady
to try and [ __ ] make sure that these
miners could breathe but what you didn't
know
is liam neeson is gonna liam neeson dude
liam neeson is gonna [ __ ] guarantee
kick some [ __ ] ass like it's
not just about weapons it's all
it's not just about finding the miners
also they've been sabotaged
we've been savita we've been sabotaged
it's time to say it's time to shave the
[ __ ] chin
[Music]
see that's when it happened man you
thought it was gonna be a boring movie
that was like up for some awards maybe
like what [ __ ] nomad land like
[ __ ] francis mcdormand oh francis
mcdormand in it too
where are you going mcdonald
my brother isn't that mine course he is
this is personal
of course it is so
irish
wow i cannot believe that [ __ ]
morpheus what's his name
is in the is in this movie lawrence
fishburne
is in this movie and not only is he in
it
so sparingly you know it okay he was in
it for a paycheck which is fine
get that money lawrence fish fish but
what i'm telling you dude
is he says sweet jesus in the trailer
twice that is some
gangster [ __ ] by the editor that's a
[ __ ] you to this movie from the editor
oh you want me to the editor of the
trailer you want me to make a trailer
cool i'll take the two times he says
sweet jesus and i'll put it in once
it's gonna keep cracking for two maybe
three thousand meters
so [ __ ] irish dude that's gonna keep
cracking
for two or three thousand meters
melt the marshmallows of the lucky
charms and use it to solder the ice
we're gonna have to run tight together
go
i mean the [ __ ] that they're just saying
[Applause]
we're coming just hang on
dude the next movie he's literally gonna
be a [ __ ] he's not even gonna be a
[ __ ] what do you call it an uh
leprechaun he's gonna be a [ __ ]
potato
just liam neeson in in [ __ ] potato
the biopic
how come he sees everything it's like he
has eyes in the back of his head
i've got eyes all over my body
i've got eyes all over me round body
[Laughter]
our lady i'm a potato
with a green hat on and still with the
[ __ ] chin
boil me up and eat me as a family just
so many [ __ ] bad
why don't you slice me up into long thin
pieces and season me and eat me with a
[Laughter]
burger
why don't you put me in a tray and do
something that [ __ ]
why don't you why don't you [ __ ]
thinly slice me and put cream
all over me and put me in a tray in an
oven for too long
and to eat me all groton her [ __ ] uh
scalloped potato
they're able to accomplish this we will
be exposed
so the question is time
we've been sabotaged the potatoes
they've been sabotaged
what is this podcast um
you gotta [ __ ] see that movie i don't
give a [ __ ] who you are you gotta see a
movie called
ice road with liam neeson it's a must
dude
you know what i [ __ ] uh actually
should have started the pa the podcast
with
oh dude because i like doing this man i
like talking about uh
postmates man these postmates drivers
are just getting out of control
they're out of control they're out of
control
i'll tell you what they are not on my
side
they're just not on my side they are
by the way i just order post mates and
[ __ ] what is the deal when two people
are in the car
what is that when it's like you see the
face
of linda and you're like here comes
linda and then
the driver dries up and it's it's like a
guy and you're like where's linda and
then the passenger seat opens up
and then she comes out here you go who's
the [ __ ] guy did you take an uber
over here to give me my postmates
who's the [ __ ] dude dude are you a
couple
which is fine but like who how are you
why are you going guy
you know what i mean if if if kristen
was like i'm gonna do uber eats
and then she was like come with me i
gotta deliver a fajita
no that's your job
please no but you cheated on me
you're right okay i'll come okay i'll
come i'll come i'll come
you know what i'm talking about dude
who's the [ __ ] other people
i swear to god one time i did a
postmates and [ __ ] four people were
in the car
they were like ready to go for a night
out
they were all dressed really nice one
time i did it it was a [ __ ]
suburban every seat even the back
[ __ ] three seats in the middle seat
they were all buckled in
and the person who was the actual
postmates was in the back seat with the
middle seat and had to unbuckle and they
had to move the chair forward and they
come out
and they're like here's your [ __ ]
[ __ ]
so i order i order it the other day
and we had a lot of [ __ ] going on in the
house there were like workers and all
this [ __ ]
and i ordered uh
i don't even remember what i ordered but
it was something quick i was like i want
to order to get it here quick i listen
to look oh this is going to be here in
75 minutes sometimes they're like
this will be here give it at least three
and a half hours
and i ordered it because it said like 25
to 35 minutes so i got it
and i'm waiting and i'm waiting and i'm
waiting and it says
your uber's here collect your food or
your [ __ ] postmates here collect your
food
i go outside guess what you know no
nowhere to [ __ ] be found
he's not even in sight
so i'm already pissed all right but i
calm down
i try to breathe i try to check in with
myself and i try to relax and i think
you know what
some things are beyond people's control
who knows what happened this guy could
have got carjacked for some [ __ ]
fajitas
so i walk outside i don't see a trace of
this [ __ ]
this guy is not
down the street and he's not up it all
right
so i do something that i hate to do
as much as i love to do i call the
[ __ ] postmates guy
i hate doing it because i don't want to
have to do it but i love doing it
because i love
being angry dude and here we go this is
the angry olympics for me
this is the biathlon of the angry
olympics for me
getting a call the [ __ ] postmates
driver because there should never be a
phone call here
there should never be a phone call for a
post based guy i got the app if i want
to do a phone call i call up
domino's order got that pizza or call
the restaurant directly and have him
deliver it but i didn't do that because
it got the app housemates
so instead of calling i use the app now
i got to call the guy so i'm in the buy
i'm in the biathlon of the angry
olympics
so i call him and he picks up great
because most of the time
they don't even pick up so my anger
subsides a little bit
and i say hello i get nothing back
and then i hear and and then i i hear
breathing and then i say hello and
then i hear the first thing that the guy
says
yeah i'm unloading something
okay so now i'm passed
but even more than that i'm very curious
because in my book the only thing you
have to unload
is the goddamn fajitas to my mouth
please just unload the fajitas in my
mouth guy all right
so i say oh you're you're what
he says yeah i'm i'm i'm up the street
i'm helping this guy unload something
and now i think okay
i'm angry but let's put that on the back
burner
because i need to know what's happening
because it must be serious
because he's not doing his job
he's not finished his job he's taken on
another job before
the first job was done now
he sounds mexican and i know mexicans
love to work and that's how much they
love to work
is that before the job is up he's like
let me do another job
so this way i'm doing two [ __ ] jobs
at once
so i look down the street first because
that will make me less mad
now why will that make me less mad
because it means he didn't
get to my house yet so at least
on the way to my house something came up
and he decided to be a good samaritan i
guess
i can accept that so i looked down the
street
nowhere to be seen i look up the street
and i see a moving van
so now i'm like this [ __ ]
is probably unloading something out of
that moving van
i guess but that means he passed my
house
which means he could have dropped off
the [ __ ] fajitas to my mouth
and then helped whoever he needed to but
still
i didn't know what was going on and i'm
on the phone with them
and i said hey
you're the you're the postmates driver
i'm talking to right because i wasn't
sure
i was 90 percent sure but that's not a
hundred
and i want to be 100 sure that this
random number
isn't is connected to the post base app
and i am calling the guy that's trying
to give me my food
so i say this is the postmates guy right
and he says yeah
like i'm the [ __ ] i
said okay this is the other thing too
he's not
saying enough words do you know what i
mean
like the only words he said so far is
yeah i'm unloading something
and yeah those are the only words he
said
and we've been on the phone for like 25
seconds so i say okay so you're
unloading something where he says yeah
i'm up the street
i'm helping these guys unload something
so i'm like okay are you bringing the
food and he says
yeah honestly i can't see it i can't see
the addresses because of the trees
ah you know how mad i am because you've
listened to this podcast 191 episodes
he said yeah but i can't see your
address because of the trees
okay but also still
do it
also use looking
also when you drive by look left
you'll see those numbers don't drive by
so fast i guess
maybe look at every house's number
because every house has a number outside
of it
maybe you're looking too hard trying to
find another job
before your first job is over
so i'm like this [ __ ] and i hear
the door behind me open
and i'm like i'm already mad don't add
[ __ ]
whoever this is it's either calvin or
kristen
don't add [ __ ] calvin can't reach a
doorknob so
alas it's kristen i turn around and she
says what are you doing
and i said okay well
i explained what happened the guy
[ __ ] he's unloading and he said he's
unloading stuff she says unloading
something and i says yeah i don't
understand her she said well don't get
mad and
[Laughter]
i'm like all right okay you know but i
gotta go
up there to see what the [ __ ] is going
on and she says why
and i was like because i i have to know
what the [ __ ] he's talking about because
he's only said six words to me
and my fajitas are getting cold she says
all right so i'm walking now and i only
have shorts on
and i've got my long feet flopping
around dude i got long [ __ ] feet
okay and i'm i'm going up the hill
and i'm getting closer and closer to
this [ __ ] moving van
and it's a u-haul truck i notice or a
u-haul truck style kind of thing and i
see on the side it says
amazon and i see behind that a car
parked a skew
now i su it's a it's the [ __ ] uber
driver
obviously because it's a skew and it's a
[ __ ] toyota celica
and so i look there's nobody in the
toyota celica
and then i look to the left and there's
[ __ ]
three guys moving something
the size of i [ __ ] you not
two and a half refrigerators it's so
big it's so unbestanquably
big that you can't [ __ ] believe it
okay
and there are three guys hoisting this
[ __ ]
refrigerator up okay of a of a curvy
stair it's not even straight it's like a
[ __ ] thing that it's like
it's like a [ __ ] it goes it doesn't
even go right angle
it like goes straight and then it goes
back to whoever designed the [ __ ]
staircase
it's like m.c escher like [ __ ] this
[ __ ] you know
it's not designed to i don't know what
was in it
it was like a [ __ ] pyramid from egypt
that was how big it was
and and and two guys
are dressed as amazon delivery guys
and the one guy is just
dressed
got a hoodie on in shorts which already
makes me mad because
are you cold or hot and he's like
really getting he's and the guy the
hoodie i i'm
i'm like okay so he's my uber driver
because he's the one who's not dressed
as the amazon shits
and and the guy with the hoodie is he's
at the bottom this guy's at the bottom
of the thing
the other two guys are up on the top
guiding it doing the fake lifting
my uber eats guy or my postmates guy is
at the bottom just like hey get it
around the top get around the top that's
all you got to do get her on the top
and i am so [ __ ] confused because the
[ __ ] toyota celica is just going ding
ding ding ding ding ding
and i see a bag of [ __ ] post mates in
the goddamn [ __ ]
and i say uh excuse me hi and and the
guy
turns around he's like oh what's up and
i say
i don't know
you tell me dude and i'm like what
what's
is i said can i just do you mind if i
just get my is this can i get my
postmates he says oh yeah yeah hold on
and he unlocks the car and goes and
grabs the food
gives it to me and he says hey man jesus
loves you
and i said yes thanks so much man i
really really appreciate it
and i trot down the hill as i'm trotting
down the hill
the owner of the house says
wait a minute you're not with these guys
and he says no he said you just stopped
to help
and he says yeah i just stopped i'm i'm
a
postmates delivery guy and he's like oh
my god what a nice guy
and i'm just like not to me though
i'm the one paying you and you're not
being nice to me
but i didn't say that but i thought it
and that's just as bad probably to jesus
christ
dude the guy [ __ ] who the [ __ ] does
that
unbelievable nicest guy in the world
that guy's a hero
unbelievable that he did that dude it
was so [ __ ] funny i couldn't believe
it
and then i rolled in and i told kristin
the story and i was like can i be
[ __ ] mad and she was like no that was
so nice of him i'm like oh dude
what are we doing what are we doing here
how does this work out if you think that
that's nice and i'm like
what's our kid gonna think
i'm raising him to think that that's
wrong i'm raising him
to think you've finished the job and if
someone's on fire
you finish your job and then put them
out
son yeah if you see someone on fire
and you're delivering mail
what do you do i drop the mail and go no
i taste them
ow what do you do i put
i put i put the mail in the box and then
i
if they're still alive i go run and put
water on them
correct son
sorry dad
oh by the way subscribe to our youtube
[ __ ] and like the [ __ ]
you know i never say this subscribe to
our youtube channel
it makes it helps dude i [ __ ] saw
sarah silverman saying it on her [ __ ]
and i'm like oh yeah i gotta say that
uh put it put it on there put put put it
on there oh i could do it like this
nah i don't like that but uh yeah
put the uh put the subscribe to our
channel do that
if you don't mind stop listening to the
podcast and do that and then let us know
again
pick it back up where you left off or
whatever the [ __ ] oh and share with your
friends too that helps too man you know
is what it is i can't believe that guy
did that with the postmates man
maybe i gotta be a better person you
know see i see [ __ ] like that
my instinct is to get mad but then i'm
like okay what am i doing wrong
how come first of all i shouldn't be mad
i shouldn't be mad
it's a waste of [ __ ] time why am i
mad i get mad at all sorts of [ __ ]
like what was the last thing i got mad
at what i do today oh i had to bring the
dog to the [ __ ] groomers
at one at kristen was like pick
you wanna take the dog or you want to
stay with the baby and i'm like
yeah whatever i'll take the [ __ ] dog
you know just doesn't matter
i'll get out so
i drive i take the dog to the [ __ ] p
not petco pet smart
pet smart i get there at one o'clock
the appointment is at 1 30
and i go to drop off the dog and they're
just like
the dog's name is cooper and by the way
it's it's our dog but it was her dog
and now it's our dog i had salmon butter
i had salmon [ __ ]
butters she had cooper and then we found
this [ __ ]
maniac chenzo in panoramic city at the
target
i got bit by a snake and ate a dead
lizard and a blue jay
or whatever the [ __ ] of a pigeon and uh
no it's a blue jay it was
joe carter in 86 he was a
blue jay in 86 they have those who don't
know i had this really bad joke it was
john alderwood
and uh so um
[Music]
no so [ __ ] uh what was i saying so so
the [ __ ]
so she so i take the dog to the groomer
and cooper has his groom these are the
groomers that cooper goes to
and i pull it up i pull up and and the
lady already is there
and i'm like i'm i'm you know what it is
about me man i'm just i'm
i'm ready to be mad that's the [ __ ]
bad thing dude
i'm ready to be mad i'm walking into a
place
that i'm gonna do business at because
i'm not a businessman but i'm a business
man
and i'm ready to be i'm ready for it to
go
[ __ ] i'm ready for it to get sideways
that's what i'm ready for
i'm that must be a self-fulfilling
prophecy that must be what it is
i'm walking in with that energy with
that dog these [ __ ] are gonna
ask me too many questions
they're gonna be like what's my phone
number or some [ __ ] you don't ever need
my [ __ ] phone number
it's on file he's been here you know
what i'm talking about
so i get there and by the way i haven't
eaten so i'm pissed because i'm probably
hypoglycemic but i have no idea what
that means but i probably am that
because people said that a lot in like
2011.
you'd walk around you'd be like i'm i'm
i'm in a bad mood people be like are you
hypoglycemic
that was the thing in 2011 people killed
it with that [ __ ]
being hypoglycemic in 2011 is like
liking the killers that was like
high up on the [ __ ] most i'm with it
shits
you know um and
uh and i bring the dog in and i'm ready
and i got my [ __ ] black shirt on and
my
my red jeans and black shoes so i'm
dressed
to [ __ ] impress dude
[Music]
and i'm walking in with koopie and
immediately i walk in is that a flat
haired is that a
a lady that works here with a mask on is
that a flat-haired retriever
and i'm just like i don't know dude i i
don't know
i i don't know dude
i wish the dog was mine from birth
so i could still not know but i didn't
want to lie to the lady so i said i
don't know
you know i i it was it it got into my
family through my
relationship and she was like yeah it's
a flat it looks like a flat hair
it's got a little flat air retriever in
it because that's a and immediately
she's charlie brown's teacher because
don't tell me all this information about
my dog that you just saw once
do you know that he [ __ ] walks around
like eeyore and he thinks everything is
his fault
or you don't cool well i do because i
know about my dog and you don't
so zip it
so i'm like ah cool yeah i'll have to
look up and now i do lie oh now i have
to i'll have to look up fl
i have to look up flat-haired retriever
after this
and i [ __ ] didn't dude because i'm
[ __ ] gangster
but anyway she's like yeah it's a flat
hair retriever
and she's like so what are we doing here
and it's one o'clock department's at 1
30. and she's and i'm like i just
brought i had to bring it in for a cut
and a a grooming
uh uh a thing and then the lady behind
the thing is
okay yeah so okay
well your groomer's not here yet
all right yeah so just um
and then the lady the flat hair lady is
just like
are you you're not gonna shave them are
you and i'm just like
what you shouldn't shave them
and i say okay
she was like if you shave them then the
hair will grow back on a flat
on a flat and i'm just like i don't even
know if it's a [ __ ] flat hair
retriever lady
she's like well the hair grows back not
the same if you shave a flat air
retriever and i'm like are you
are you just trying to tell me your
knowledge about dogs like i'm gonna
assume you know a lot about dogs
you work at petsmart smarts in the title
and so is dog pet
you know you're a smart person a lot
about pets when i walk in you don't have
to [ __ ]
you know what i mean you're like one of
those [ __ ] religious guys that
that just feels people and he's like oh
you're who you kreskin
so i'm like all right yeah i won't i
guess not shave him i don't know i just
he comes in here all the time
just whatever it is to to do it and
she's like okay yeah
and then they're like yeah he's getting
a cut and then the lady with the
the said the flat hair stuff was like oh
and the appointment's at 1 30. oh
sh okay well we can't take him and i was
like what
she's like we can't take we can't take
him because it's not 1 30 yet and i'm
like well i was just gonna drop him off
and then you can get to him when you get
to him he's like nah we can't do that
we're not a business like that
because uh we gotta wait till your
groomer gets here and i was like okay
well where is she
she's at lunch she'll probably be back
around 1 30 and i'm like okay
okay didn't lash out remembered
i tried to [ __ ] be good i tried to
use my therapy to try and just calm
myself down not myself because i don't
have a lisp and i'm not mike tyson
myself so i take koopie and i get i say
koopie get up in the [ __ ] car get up
in the car i go get a coffee because you
know your boy loves iced americanos
and a [ __ ] extra coffee i slurped
that up
and i got it and i also got some sweet
greens ate the [ __ ] out of the sweet
greens and then i drove back
and i was excited now let me tell you
why
i was excited because it was 131
and i couldn't wait i couldn't wait for
them to give me [ __ ] about how he was
late i was praying
that the info lady was in there with a
mask on just talking about
oh we actually it's actually because
he's late and we're gonna have to
i was praying for it so i could turn
into
super scion crystalia dude and just
really let that mountain range come out
really explode out the back of my shirt
like a goddamn ninja turtle like i'm the
[ __ ]
american werewolf in sherman oaks just
blasting off those hikers trying to get
up those [ __ ] double black diamond
ski slopes
just blasting off those [ __ ]
skiers and snowboarders
just ready
and i brought him in i said hey here's
cooper it was 136 by the time i got in
and i was showing up [ __ ] ready and
they said oh thank you and i just gave
it to him and that was it
so my point of the story is it doesn't
really go the way you think it's gonna
go you make up all this [ __ ] in your
head dude
and it's a waste of [ __ ] time now for
me it's great
because it makes me money i come on here
and i tell you about it but if you're a
regular person with no podcast
and not an entertainer don't bother
yourself with that [ __ ]
i'll get cancer because of that
dude it's just like this
man um
[Music]
actually the truth is i did go back and
they still asked a bunch of [ __ ]
questions and i was just like i don't
know
and they were like i'm gonna do a pet
assessment of the dog and i'm just like
cool you know
he's really simple you don't have to
talk to me like this you know in my head
i'm just like you can just do whatever
you got to do
okay and do we want to even cut all over
the rest of the
all over the body do we want an even cut
all over the body and if
i say yes because i'm not a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you know what i mean i'm not one of
these people that cuts their dog's
body at different length in their face
like they're a show
like dude you don't have a show dog dude
you know what i mean you live in ventura
county
just get your dog use a flowbee for
[ __ ] sake
whatever shitsu who gives a [ __ ] run
that flow be over the shih tzu
those are two things that shouldn't be
words floaby and shitsu and i sent him
in one sentence
but um yeah dude
petsmart petsmart's where it's at
probably
so then i went to go pick them up and it
was all good and you smelled like a
[ __ ] inside of an oldsmobile when you
get the freshener in it
they [ __ ] just make it smell too much
the dog the dog comes in it's like oh
god
my girl's gonna come cheating if you
[ __ ] run all over me
did you [ __ ] a dog
did you [ __ ] the inside of an oldsmobile
no
[Music]
um
subscribe to the youtube channel i did
it again i did it again i said it again
subscribe to the youtube channel
it's so funny how much the internet and
or just texting
has like the way people are
you can see how they are with the [ __ ]
like i was looking at
at this instagram i was going through
instagram
with kristin and we were just like
laughing at people on instagram
just like two good people do two really
good people do just going on instagram
and laughing at people's
faces basically because we're looking at
their faces just two nice people just
sitting in bed just laughing in people's
faces on instagram
just like two just sweet people you know
and uh we found this one girl
who is did this thing
where she was like with another girl
just sitting with each other and their
faces are close to each other
and she says how does it continue wrong
answers only
and we were like okay we know how it
continues you know but what are the
wrong answers
um
where's the one word of the guy
here here's one this guy writes this
under it
i bust through the door and both of you
look at me and say
we've been waiting for you you sexy hunk
of a man
what took you so long poppy come here
papi chulo these clothes aren't going to
take themselves
ended the sentence a little early there
didn't you buddy
but uh this was the these two comments
were two of the greatest comments i've
ever seen on instagram
this one says for me you can doing
anytime do you like one kiss flying as
dust yes like stardust is always love
you can d d e
uh just so many words
so many words to have not a sentence in
it
like i get if you didn't make a sentence
and you had five words
because it's like okay you could have
added maybe a few more words and made a
sentence
but there's so many words here and not
one sentence
he did it dude he cracked the code
but that one is not as good as this one
to me
oh please finish that's so wild and
amazingly beautiful when women make love
and get so into each other i don't care
for two men
no oh no
hey guy
all good but
hey it's all good that you said that in
public
and in a public forum but in
secrecy
you privately switch
dude how
can you ah
that's like the [ __ ] comment from the
dad from american beauty
so funny man
oh wow somebody writes
wow s-o-s s-o-s s-o-s go to the bathroom
go to bathroom and brush your teeth and
tits
what brush your tits
what is what it what how does this
happen here is another comment from from
a guy
he leaves two comments he leaves two
comments
the first one is i love you dearly
you're my son
and then right under it he writes do you
are you dislike
like even if you're foreign which i'm
assuming he is
what you're my son
imagine seeing two chicks make out
you're my son
just the [ __ ] unbelievable
[ __ ] that goes on on the internet
oh wait this guy wrote
i think with your savvy and beauty
everything will turn into your beautiful
the way you want kisses the way to you
[Laughter]
kisses the way to you
wow these guys just want to meet
[ __ ] in the comments
that's what it is you just want to meet
how lonely are you that you comment on
anything dude
i got [ __ ] you know what's actually
kind of annoying nowadays is how much
people are
talking about the [ __ ] ufos that are
like
hey the government said and it's like
the government always lies the media
always lies
when people say look into it it doesn't
mean anything
there's so much information out there
fake and real there's no way to
distinguish it
like when people are like look into it
dude what do you mean
look into what the real information or
the fake information
it's all out there oh yeah but if you
look into it you'll be able to discern
what's
how how
the new york times says one thing
[ __ ] l.a time says another thing
they both say different things one's
wrong or they both say the same thing
and they're both [ __ ] wrong
and the government's going to tell us
that's what they or your government lies
to you you need to vote republican or
your government last year you need to
vote vote democrat your government lies
to us whether it's [ __ ] democrat or
republican
vote who the [ __ ] you want to vote for
it doesn't [ __ ] matter at this point
you're going to get lied to no matter
[ __ ] what dude and half the country
is going to be mad at it
so now i'm it's like this ufo [ __ ] it's
like yeah the government said this and
you gotta look into in the ufo
dude show me a [ __ ] ufo footage that
doesn't look like a black dot
in the middle of a goddamn gray and
write screen show me
that [ __ ] show me the ufo up close
ah but the aliens don't like it when you
get too close oh yeah
there's that [ __ ] 900 million billion
people in this world
we would have footage it's like the
[ __ ] bigfoot thing
and i'm i don't not believe in ufos i
don't not believe in aliens
i do think that there's other life forms
out there but my point is
don't tell me that you know where they
are and what happened and what you saw
when there's never been good footage and
i'm gonna get lit up
from that because internet [ __ ]
are dorks they're gonna be like
uh well actually it's funny to say that
because there was a place you know a lot
of people think the hot spot is roswell
but in actuality it's
somewhere uh in northern dakota and
there is footage about no there's not
dude no there's not
every [ __ ] every ufo that i've ever
seen with the grain
it looks like a speck of something in
your teeth that's what it looks like
that's what it always looks like when
you first see something in someone's
teeth you're like
is that is something in their teeth or
not and then you look you're like oh
yeah something is in their teeth or
you're looking oh you never mind i
thought there was but there wasn't
it's always that oh yeah i thought that
was the word oh it [ __ ] stayed
i was watching the [ __ ] show the
other day and it was like
the the ufo was up was was up in the air
and there was like this is the most
compelling ufo
evidence that we've ever seen it stopped
in the middle of the uh
air and then it goes underwater and i'm
like oh cool we get to see this thing
dive under water dude it's so far away
it's this [ __ ] big it's this big
and it's just sitting there it could be
a [ __ ] a [ __ ] up on the film
and then it just goes blunk into the
ocean i guess
and some guy's always over the thing
just
yeah that's a little real there's yeah
seeing it
going there it's got a it's at least 900
knots it's going 70 not
it's in it no there's no no no ship on
the thing that could
get closer
it's just funny because i don't know how
how close you can get if it's actually
a an object that's out of this world
that obviously came
faster than the speed of light so do you
tell me how a ship tanker can can catch
up to that
unless we forget it's a ship tanker
uh we gotta can't get too close
i just i'm tired of it dude everyone who
posts
all of the ufo [ __ ] the conspiracies
theorists you're
so high all the time you know what i'm
talking about
like you're so high all the time
whoa like you ever see joe rogan's post
you know what i mean of a ufo
he's like crazy [ __ ] 2021 getting crazy
and you're like oh dude he's
high it's 1am do you know what i'm
talking about
it was like a a post and and everyone's
like see
told you the government said more than
ever and then his next post is about
like he it's like a [ __ ]
he's he he's like i'm eating elk you're
like oh he's high
and i and by the way i i love joe rogan
obviously he he's a friend but like the
i and and by the way i believe in aliens
all i'm saying is don't show me the
[ __ ] evidence
that is in evidence
the universe is [ __ ] it goes real
far you know in vegas when you're in one
hotel and you're like let's just walk to
the other hotel
and and you're like oh yeah it's right
there and you're walking for you're like
i thought it was right here
it's the next one over do you know how
many
of those are in a universe
like 35 there's like 35 of those
that's the universe you would never walk
the universe
and out of this world that have eight
billion people
there's it's always a fleck of it's
always a speck of
it's a speck one guy didn't brush up
against a [ __ ] nano nano
one guy one guy in nebraska
wasn't [ __ ] trumping along the
cornfields and just went hey what the
[ __ ]
and then
what is that [ __ ] i got slime on me
never happened
ever i watched that [ __ ] thing on the
uh
uh the the the thing on [ __ ] hulu or
walker ranch or whatever the [ __ ] it's
called walker texas
that's the ranger texas ranch
and it's like un inexplicable things we
had to go underground and there's a
reading underground and they're in
under the ground and they're like yeah i
stepped down here and i
immediately just felt there's something
dude
you're an [ __ ]
people think i'm a dick i get it i'm not
a dick this is all jokes
but don't crawl down 10 feet and be like
oh something's something's
one time i texted uh kristen about
a watch i thought i wanted to buy and
she didn't respond for [ __ ]
three hours and i was like why is she
not responding about the [ __ ] watch i
wanted to get
and i texted her back she doesn't
text her back with the claps i texted
you know how they do with the claps that
text back she doesn't
care about my well-being folks
and then i looked and i i realized i
sent voltex to my realtor
imagine being a realtor you're looking
for a house for a client and they text
you hey i'm thinking about getting this
watch
and then you don't text him back for
three hours and and you text a realtor
she doesn't care about my well-being
folks
oh [ __ ] and then she was like no i like
watches and i'm like no no it was a
mistake
you know it was a mistake and i i told
her it was a mistake she's like yeah but
i like watches if you want to go what
i'm like
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] anyway that's all i
really have to say about that
um thanks for listening this is another
episode of congratulations and you know
what the merch flew off uh there's no
more
of that there might be like one or two
items left of the of the new life rips
colorways and design those were the [ __ ]
uh
they [ __ ] sold out and i don't know i
may bring them back i'm not sure
uh but they just they did really well
and um
like and subscribe i never say this but
subscribe dude
do your boy a solid and subscribe to the
channel
we love it dude we love it we love when
you subscribe to the channel if you're a
true baby
you subscribe to that channel and we
love it what's up baby that's the
episode
and uh that's it that's the episode for
youtube i should say if you want
the extended version the uncut version
um then you can go on over to our
patreon and
watch it there uh it's uh
patreon.comcrystalia that's what you got
to do you got to go over to patreon.com
and uh click the link there and then
it'll tell you what to do you get uh
access to behind the scenes stuff
uh there are other hidden episodes
and you also get an extra episode a
month so
um it's content content content my baby
patreon.com kristalia thanks
[Music]
congratulations
thank you
was that an hour and 20. it was